And everybody, this is Dr. Cutters, and I'm going to talk in this section about what
other tests could I or should I do?
So this is for our patients, commonly asked questions trying to cover this to help you
walk through this decision-making process.
There's a lot of tests out there that you could do or should do.
First of all, we're going to cover the tests typically that your oncologist is going to
recommend.
So typically, your oncologist is going to recommend CT scans, PET scans, MRIs, maybe bone
scans, biopsies, more invasive type things.
We're not going to cover that in this section here, but I will say, when I say these are
invasive tests, I don't mean that you should avoid them at all costs.
Many times, they're important to do, especially if you're following a protocol from your
oncologist, meaning you're doing some sort of standards of care, like radiation or chemotherapy
or surgery or something, you're going to need to follow their recommendations.
Now I call them invasive tests because there is some invasiveness to them.
You do a CT scan.
Those are sectional tests, like you're going to do an upper bodies CT or abdominal CT.
Each one of those sectional CTs carries about the rad dose of radiation of about 50 chest
x, right?
So they're not something that you should just do to satisfy your curiosity.
It's something that you do to change your decision-making process and how you're going to treat
the patient.
There's times that you have to do that.
We need to see if this cancer has grown.
This person has, you know, some signs and symptoms of worsening and we're going to change our
protocol, maybe change the chemotherapy.
Should it be true that the cancer's growing?
We need to do another CT scan to compare with the last CT scan that we did x about a month
ago.
Well, the only way to compare that is to compare apples to apples, and that is to do another
of the same tests that you did prior that brought you to that decision-making process that
you're following through with right now.
So there's times that a CT scan, PET scan, MRI is very appropriate.
You just have to know that there are risks to it.
Typically MRIs are going to be done with a contrast, die, and typically that's gadolinium, and
that does build up in your system.
Some people have very difficult time to talk to if I can have reactions to it.
So MRIs are not without their risk, either, even though there's no radiation.
So there's a time and place for invasive tests.
That's a discussion that we could have individually.
That's something that definitely you need to do if you're following standards of care.
But just to do them to satisfy curiosity, if it's not going to change the way it treat the
patient, I don't know if that's the right decision-making process.
But what we want to concentrate on in this video is what are the less invasive tests that
I could do that could help me move my care in a different way.
That gives me some more data to, you know, change maybe by nutritional protocol, a little
better, tweak something in my protocol.
These I would say are less invasive tests, an ultrasound, thermography, labs.
Of course a lab is invasive because they stick you at the needle to draw blood, but it's certainly
not, you know, typically harmful.
There's not going to be any lasting issues with that.
So let's talk about some of these tests that we more often recommend.
So the first is an ultrasound.
No, an ultrasound would only be appropriate depending upon the type of cancer that you have.
So if you have prostate cancer, they're not going to do an ultrasound to see if your prostate
cancer's grown.
But if you have breast cancer, and you haven't had a lump back to be or a mastectomy, and you're
looking for a change in size, if that may be an appropriate test.
Now your oncologist may argue that, oh, you get a much better idea of where it's at if
we do another MRI, but we've had patients that opted out of MRIs because of the contrast
die, and they wanted to do just follow their cancer with an ultrasound.
Well, that seems reasonable.
So an ultrasound could be a reasonable test for things like that.
An ultrasound could be a reasonable test for bile duct issues, and gallbladder issues,
and some abdominal type cancers.
An ultrasound could be a reasonable test to see and guide further care.
Thermography could be another reasonable test, especially with breast cancer or head and neck
issues, head and neck cancers.
But abdominal cancers, no, not really, prostate cancer, no.
But breast cancer, you could use thermography as a guide to, you know, as the cancer, you
know, am I improving or not improving?
The problem is, is that sometimes when you're killing the cancer effectively, either using
chemotherapy or using the right and nutrition, the cancer can look hotter on thermography
because you are stimulated in immune response to the cancer.
That's what we're really trying to do.
This gets your immune system to kill the cancer, and the thermography can't actually look
worse.
So you have to know that with any test.
That could happen with the CT scanner MRI as well, and the same thing with an ultrasound.
If you're effectively killing the cancer, and your immune system is, is populating a reaction
to the tumor, the tumor can look larger for a period of time because you're causing this
state of local inflammation as your immune system is attacking it.
So you can get what's called a pseudo enlargement of a tumor or a pseudo-worsity of a cancer because
it's your body's actually doing what it's supposed to be doing what we want it to do.
So you just have to understand that with any testing.
The next is a laboratory testing.
The laboratory test is something we really like to see, and it's some lab tests your
oncologist will recommend.
So that's what we're going to spend more of our time on this video, and this is where
the slide gets a little bit more comprehensive.
So laboratory testing could be broken down into three categories, some of your standard tests,
and then we could call them some specific lab tests that are specific to cancer, and then
some functional labs.
So the standard labs that your oncologist or your general practitioner may already be doing
are things like a CDC, that's a complete blood count, or a complete metabolic panel, which
is going to measure your alkaline phosphid, your liver, function tests, and understand different
labs have different names for these.
There's all sorts of, there's no standardization necessarily for names of labs, except for
some of the general ones like CBC and a complete metabolic panel.
Then there's a comprehensive lipid panel where we get into the breakdown and different
labs have different tests for that, where you get into not just your LDLs and HDLs, but
you get into oxidized LDLs and HDLs and things, and that gives you a much better idea of
how the fats of your body are doing, and typically we're not interested in that so much
with cancer.
So comprehensive lipid panel wouldn't be really anything you'd really necessarily do with
cancer, except that, just because you have cancer doesn't mean you don't have other things
going on.
You have the right to have more than one problem at one time that you may want to address.
So that may be something, and it is something that we have ordered or told people to order
in the past.
It's like your thyroid panel.
Well, if you have liver cancer, colon cancer, what do you care about your thyroid panel?
Well, to be honest, you should care about it, because if you do have hypothyroid or
Hashimoto's or something like that, that could really affect your ability to enlist it
in a beauty response if your thyroid is low, and your energy is going to be low, you're
going to have fatigue issues, that's just quality of life issues.
It's not good to be walking around with low thyroid, worse to be walking around with
high thyroid.
So it's something that you may want to address, and it's something just because again, you
have cancer doesn't mean we can't look at other things too.
Other specific labs to cancer would be mainly just the tumor marker tests, and we'll get
into detail with that.
And tumor marker tests have a place, and you have to understand that place.
So we'll talk about that just in just a second.
And then functional tests.
So before we were really a specific cancer clinic for years, we did a lot of functional
tests, different nutrient tests, different what's called an oat test, which is an organic
acid test, mold test, parasite stool test, I mean, there's literally dozens and dozens
and dozens of different functional tests that you can test for, and you can spend a lot
of money on different tests, and they can give us different data.
Specific to the cancer, not really specific to the cancer, but certainly if you have mold
issues or parasite issues and different things, it's going to hinder your body's immune response
to be able to kill the cancer.
But many times, the reason why we don't do a lot of functional tests with our cancer patient
is that many times our cancer patients are taking care of themselves because of the cancer.
Better than we could ever have gotten our sick patients, our autoimmune patients years
past, even doing an oat test in a mold test, a parasite, getting them motivated to follow
their diet and such.
That still wasn't enough.
So most of our cancer patients are following a strict, regimented good nutrition and specific
nutrients that will be addressing a lot of those things anyhow.
So if a person came to us and said, I just got diagnosed with cancer and I want to do all
these labs, well, certainly we can.
It does get expensive to do all those labs, but it certainly can be done.
We can do food sensitivity testing.
We can do different side rec antibody tests and there's a whole bunch of stuff that I love
to do.
They're fun to look at.
It takes a lot of time, though.
So you have to realize that if we do our cheek swab test and we're doing our diet and we're
doing specific nutrition to the cancer, many times a lot of those results of those tests.
If you had ill results of those tests, day one of your treatment, they would have resolved
themselves at 12 weeks in or six months in.
So we don't really see that there's a particular necessity to do any of those tests.
If a person comes to us and they're doing really well, they're in a relative state of
remission, but they want to start addressing some other things that they have going out of
their body.
Well, certainly we can run some of those panels.
We have the ability to run any possible functional medicine tests that you can imagine.
So just contact us and we can run those tests.
So we charge other tests.
We just charge the cost of the lab and then you pay for our time to go over it with you.
So just so you know.
And then the hormone test, the Dutch hormone test, it's called a Dutch dried urine hormone
test.
That's the best type of hormone test out there.
That's the most common functional test that we run on cancer patients.
They're typically female cancer patients that we run that test on and let's talk about
those.
The most common tests that we ask people to run.
So now why do we ask people to run them?
Because if you have insurance and I know the days are changing and people have, you know,
$10,000 deductible insurance policies, but if you've already met that deductible and you
have a physician, a local physician that will run these labs and they will get covered
under your insurance, well, by all means, we want the best for you.
So if you can ask your physician to run those, then that would be best.
But I'll tell you a little secret.
We work with a company called Wellivate and we run our labs through that and they run through
lab core.
So for instance, a tumor marker panel, a pretty complete tumor marker panel that we would
recommend for females, which is more tumor markers than we recommend for males.
I think it's $74 or something like that plus a $7 draw fee if you go to lab core lab,
which Wellivate will help set up for you and you'll be able to locate the closest lab
core draw site.
So we can order any of these tests for you.
We cannot order and will not order a CT pet's get an MRI nor will we order an ultrasound.
We can help you find somebody to do a thermography with.
We can help you order 80 of the laboratory testing.
So we can order that and a lot of times it's a lot less expensive.
So you will pay for our time to go over it and that's only if you want to go over quite
honestly.
A lot of people that a lot of our patients at least have been in this process have looked
at their CBCs for the last several years and they can look at their CBCs and make sure
their hemoglobin is still in a healthy range or not and they don't need to go over it with
us but we'll be happy to do that.
Now some specific details on the tumor markers.
Here's the typical tumor marker.
This is our tumor marker panel that we like to see for females.
It's a CA153, CA199, CA2729, CA2125, CEA and LDH.
Now if you are like what did he just say?
There is a blog post on our site.
If you just search in a little search thing, tumor markers, you'll see a blog post on
tumor markers that go into detail explaining these.
So the CA153 is really specific to breast cancer so as the CA2729 but the CA199 can be
more specific to pa- uh to pa- to pa- to pa- to cancer.
It can show up on breast cancer as well.
CA125 and the CEA can be for ovarian cancers.
They can be for abdominal cancers.
LDH can be for any cancer and PSA is specific to prostate.
So that would be only for males.
But these would be the panels that we would run and they range from about 50 to 75 dollars
plus your draw fee.
So it's fairly inexpensive.
We can order those for you.
So contact your liaison, contact the clinic and we can order that panel for you if you're
a full cancer patient with us.
We can order the CBC and the complete metabolic panel.
We like to order one that has a whole bunch more than that too and the cost of that I think
gosh we can do- there's one for 75 and then there's a full one for 145 or something like
that.
So it's fairly inexpensive for those panels and so just let us know we can order those
for you.
The- I did want to share the Dutch hormone test.
That is one that typically we would do only for women usually and it would be for if you
have a female cancer so a female with colon cancer really we don't need to do a Dutch
test.
A female with breast cancer or a variant cancer we still don't need to do a Dutch test but
it is something that we can do.
Why wouldn't we want to do a Dutch test?
Because in most cases if you've been on a nutritional protocol what we're really looking for in the
Dutch test what it does is it breaks down all the metabolites of your hormone so the different
metabolites of progesterone, testosterone and sometimes most important the metabolites of estrogen.
Yes you have about 33 different metabolites of estrogen circulated in your body all the
time.
It is really a couple of them that we would call the quote unquote bad estrogens and those
are the ones that we want to look for.
Some of these hydroxylated estrogens normally they have to they're in your body their metabolites
meaning that it breaks down to that and then should break down to something else and get out
of your body but it's when that bad estrogen builds up on your body then it could be a problem.
To be honest with you all the years doing Dutch tests we typically don't do them until after
we start a treatment process and I have never seen the bad estrogens out of balance I shouldn't
say that.
A couple times but hardly ever do you see it because we have the woman on things like dim and
astro clear and you know different nutrition to help support detox pathways and such that
are really helping clear those out and binders that are helping you to not reabsorb those.
So we are already deled with that and it's rare that the Dutch test when we do it really
changes their course of action.
So it's fun information and it's really it is really cool to look at but it really doesn't
change our course of action so I don't recommend it that often.
The tumor markers I did want to touch on that again because what other thing about the
tumor markers that you have to know is that tumor markers can be sometimes not a good
sign.
So if you're doing a if you're doing chemotherapy there isn't an oncologist in the country
that's going to suggest tumor markers because typically if you're doing chemotherapy you're
causing cell lysis that's a different type of cell that the cell is dying pathologically
due to the chemotherapy and it's going to spill this protein.
Tumor markers are proteins are enzymes that are produced by a growing cancer not all cancers
will will spill out tumor markers so you could have a stage 4 cancer that's growing aggressively
and all your tumor markers are within normal limits just so you know then they don't really
become valuable to test it all but you don't know that until you do a test.
But if you do have to a marker that's own a balance you can possibly I say that possibly
use it as an indicator of how your cancer is doing.
If your tumor marker is going up and up and up and up that's an indication that your cancer
could be growing but the truth is it's also an indication that your cancer could be rapidly
dying in the case of using chemotherapy could it be rapidly dying in the case of using natural
things well maybe too but any test whether it's a PET scan a CT scan an MRI ultrasound anything
or a tumor marker test you don't use one test to say oh this person's doing worse or oh
this person's doing better you have to guard that test and balance it with other sides and
symptoms other objective and subjective findings if I'm feeling fantastic but my PSA is going
through the roof with my prostate cancer that could be well do I have growth in my prostate
cancer well it could be I don't have any other sides and symptoms so I have to weigh it out
maybe I need to do another test so all tests regardless of what the tests are are just indicators
they're just little signs they're just little flags they're little hints of something could
be going on maybe it tells us we need to dig a little bit more maybe that's when we get into more
invasive tests that's why you do a test it's not a diagnostic side in itself but it gives you signals
to balance out through differential diagnosis what is the right thing the right way to go and how
this person is going so remember that when we do any of these tests because I don't want to it'll be
having discussions and talking you off the cliff when your CA2729 jumps up 10 points but the rest
of our balance but you feel great so it could really mean nothing it was just that specific time
of day that they drew the blood that that that marker was higher so you have to remember that that's
why it's good to do tests on a regular basis to run these on a regular basis and that's why I'm glad
that they're not all that horribly expensive so they are affordable to do if you do tests with us
we will get those results back if you do them through our program through elevate we'll get those
test results back in our folder and we will inform you when we get those results back if you do the
test through your um general practitioner or through your oncologist or your naturopath locally
well then you have to tell us that you got those tests back and you email them to labs at countersclinic.com
you email them to labs at countersclinic.com preferably a PDF of that lab so let us know you'll get a
standard email back that says if you want to go over these it's up to you to tell us so when we
get labs they go in your portal everybody has a uh EHR electronic health record in our office and
that goes into your health records so that we can review it but we are not gonna view it and go over
and then make a decision to call you you are gonna have to make a decision if you want us to have a
discussion so just like any other office visit you will have to pay for that office visit for us
to discuss your labs so just understand that so if the cost of your lab if you haven't done it a
naturopathics office or your oncologist office and they're upcharging you the cost of the lab because
that's including a discussion about the lab or that you should have that discussion with them about
the lab so just so you know so if you need to talk you have a concern you just need to understand
what the lab means um you need a retest you need to think about doing a cheek swab again whatever you
need to contact us so we're always a phone call away so just let us know and know that we're here
to talk we're here to bounce ideas if your lab's got way worse don't freak out we're here to talk to
you and retest you and tweak things that's our promise we can't promise that we're gonna get you
better that you're not gonna have cancer anymore or that you're gonna be healthy and you're gonna
live to 172 when we can promise that we'll do everything we can to move you in the right direction
for your goals that's all we can do everything else is in God's hands and he's sovereign over everything
so and we will be praying for you so if you just need somebody to talk to and to pray with you call
us and let us know because we want what's best for you so hopefully that explains what you should do
should I do other tests could I do other tests you want more details make an appointment with
your liaison or myself or Michelle and dumb we can help you walk through that as well thanks